one of the nutrients that is the most
depleted from consuming carbohydrates
can anyone take a wild guess vitamin b1
so I want to spend a little time because
this one's really important vitamin b1
thiamine E it's called berry berry yeah
a lot of people have almost like a
subclinical deficiency in their body
it's called the great mimicker because
it mimics so many other diseases you're
gonna see that it has extensive
mimicking ability for all these problems
what does b1 do well basically it makes
myelin the protective sheath around your
nervous system that what happens when
you're a diabetic you basically you lose
the myelin because the high sugar
oxidizes the fat layer around the cell
it's called lipid oxidation and by the
way b1 protects the myelin from being
damaged and that's why if you have
peripheral neuropathy you can take b1
and actually improve those symptoms
pretty quick if they made a fat soluble
B vitamin it's called benfotiamine which
is even a better remedy because it
penetrates the fat cells a lot more than
actually the just the regular thiamine
so benfotiamine can penetrate penetrate
the brain by 25 times more than regular
b1 so it's really good for neurological
conditions brain problems nerve problems
peripheral neuropathy and your
fingertips in the in the toes so that's
one thing B one protects to sell
especially the mitochondria against the
damage from high sugar if you take two
diabetics with high sugar and you have
one of them this deficient of b1 the
other ones not the one of the ones
that's deficient in b1 will experience
the complications a lot more than the
person has B 1 so b1 suppresses the
complications from high sugar so it
protects the mitochondria
why because b1 is the cofactor for at
least 5
enzymes in the mitochondria so it's it
acts as a sparkplug it works with
magnesium so I took a long time to try
to figure out how to explain this in a
simple way to take the biochemistry
really simple because you have how many
of you took biology in high school
remember studying about the Krebs cycle
yeah how many really don't remember
anything about it
okay good yeah so the krebs cycle is
basically a motor it's a machine that
goes that turns food into energy so you
have a carburetor right how many of you
know what a carburetor is okay good so
basically you mix gas with air at the
right ratio and you have a spark plug
and then it ignites right you have
energy that's what that's what the Krebs
cycle is so it's just making energy you
need B one so I was trying to figure out
how to demonstrate that so I created a
little video okay I'm blowing gasoline
onto a blowtorch and now we're going to
take away b1 create a b1 deficiency no
ignite
you can't ignite it
I couldn't think of any other way to
demonstrate that so I mean I'm fried a I
was preparing for this and I said Karen
sees me with this this roadside flame
thing right because what do you do with
that
I said no everyone's doing on YouTube
it's a really great experiment so it's
raining outside and I said just take a
video of this so I put cornstarch in my
mouth and I blew it and it actually
could you looks like you're blowing
gasoline so don't try that at home but
the right ratio of fuel to oxygen you
can ignite it with B 1 and this is why
be one deficiencies create fatigue
big-time especially if you doing keto if
you're tired if you're going through
keto dictations and your keto fatigue b1
and need to be vitamins as well it'll
actually bring your energy way up you
need magnesium as well those two so b1
is considered a nerve vitamin because it
creates so many problems with the nerve
if you're deficient in it it's a helper
factor so these enzymes that do all this
chemistry need b1 as an essential
cofactor if you don't have b1 these
enzymes cannot work now what creates a
b1 deficiency sugar high the more
carbohydrates you consume the more b1
deficient you're going to be also if you
don't have enough b1 you build up lactic
acid called lactic acidosis that's why
the metformin the side effect is b1 and
you get all this lactic acid they can
change your ph and they can change your
breathing you're like can't get enough
air mitochondria the energy factory of
the body so if you have too much sugar
you're gonna choke out or flood the
engine basically and you're going to be
tired so b1 deficiency is intimately
involved with cardiovascular function
and respiratory functions so you can get
a large heart edema difficulty breathing
blood pressure problems palpitations
increased pulse rate but a lot of times
when you actually get this test
did it shows normal because you have to
do a very special test
it's called trance he too late Trane's
he too late so everyone say that trance
Kito late okay good so you do that test
and you can pick up b1 but it's very
hard to find this test it's very
expensive so much better just to take 2
b1 and then you can feel better you know
you had a deficiency so digestion GERD
why would be one effect GERD because be
one can is intimately involved in the
autonomic nervous system which is
basically controlling all the valves of
the body so you get GERD and the valve
doesn't close and the acid goes up
you'll feel the full sensation in your
stomach you can get an ulcer
gastroparesis which is the sluggishness
of food going through the digestive
tract so the autonomic nervous system
that it's the system that works behind
the scenes that works not automatic
there are tremendous amounts of weird
symptoms that you get from this I'm
going to cover a couple but it's just
like like you lose your ability to like
your tear ducts don't release tears
anymore so I mean like you wouldn't
think that's connected to b1 so lack of
tears excessive sweating if you get on
the shower use breaking a sweat
b1 deficiency anxiety nervous tension
when you take b1 you just feel like this
sudden relief there's a condition called
pots which I'm not going to kind of I'm
just going to briefly go over these but
you get up too fast and you feel dizzy
and you fall down there's a whole group
of people who have this condition it's 2
b1 deficiency usually brain fog double
vision difficulty swallowing exercise
intolerance anyone have that yeah
b1 gives you energy so you'll actually
when you exercise also any of the
autoimmune disorders if you're fatigued
from that can be improved especially
Hashimoto's and MS if you're tired you
take B 1 it can prove that because it
helps improve the enzyme for the
mitochondria so it's one of the most
common things that I recommend when I
was in practice and also now and it just
works it's like a no brainer it's
inexpensive if you do if you I'm not
saying you should you can't use the
synthetic but also use like nutritional
yeast or a natural version of vitamin B
as well because anytime you take one
fraction of a vitamin for a long period
of time it could create imbalances
vertigo balance problems impaired taste
so the autonomic nervous system you have
two parts parasympathetic which is rest
and digest and then sympathetic which is
flutter fight so part of the sympathetic
nervous system is embedded inside the
adrenal and so you got this interesting
gland on the adrenals on top of the
kidney because the it's it's half
nervous system and half gland so it's
right in the abdomen so you get this
quick release of adrenaline to act you
know create different effects but the
imbalance in this system can happen from
a b1 deficiency hiccups how many of ever
had a hiccup take some b1 reoccurred ear
infections mental stress anyone ever
experience stress at least once in your
life one two three okay
it really helps stress panic attacks
nightmares I used to eat my kids I used
to give him b1 if they had a nightmare
just jam handles it so its involved in
so many things a TD autism if you're a
coach and you're coaching people it'd be
a really good thing to recommend I want
to touch on this structure in your brain
called the hippocampus it's kind of like
a relay switch into your database memory
system it you don't know exactly what it
does but it's involved in memory and
your ability to locate yourself and time
and space so how many are really good at
driving somewhere and finding directions
in your area whether you live
you're not good at that yeah you need a
GPS right so it has to do with this
hippocampus birds have these huge
structures in their brain and they can
they can just flood south and they know
where to go
hippocampus is involved in that so hit
the hippocampus has receptors for b1 so
if you're deficient in B one you can
affect that you're going to start
noticing that you're going to go in a
room and can't quite remember why you
went in there how many of ever
experienced that at least once okay good
they call 911 now so what happens is how
you can become b1 deficient is all the
carbohydrates all the carbohydrates I'm
going to deplete your b1 so there's a
tremendous amount of additional things
like related to your digestion your
heart your brain and I gave you guys a
chart on all the different symptoms I'm
not going to go through all of them but
you can see that there's anything from
depression and definitely if you're
trying to if you lost if you're
exercising and you lost that inertia and
you just you lost that get-up-and-go
it's usually b1 b1 affects part of the
autonomic nervous system that innervates
the brainstem especially the respiratory
centers so there's a condition called
SIDS sudden infant death syndrome
there's a lot of research related to you
know these infants dying and then
finally there's the b1 deficiency
probably from the infant formula it's
all glucose you know sleep apnea b1 it's
also related to high insulin because the
sugar pulls out b1 so b1 is a really
important protecting this cell against
damage and also helping the enzymes work
in your mitochondria it also mimics
mercury poisoning and mercury depletes
b1 so here's some things that will
deplete it white rice diuretics refined
sugar and carbs coffee
yep too much if you actually drink
coffee and you have b1 after it you feel
a lot better
a gastric bypass because most of the lot
of the b1 is absorbed in the small
intestine so if you're bypassing that
small of your intestine yeah you could
have a problems with the absorption
aging metformin cooking diabetes all
diabetics type 1 and type 2 should be
taking b1 and the B complex with the
cells of the pancreas that are damaged
or overworking or under working they're
not you're not going to be able to pull
in B vitamins that well so the minimum
dosage of B is not enough you need more
to actually penetrate the cells that
regulate insulin too much chocolate of
course different chemical properties in
coffee tea chocolate and wine can
deplete b1 if you have a lot over a
period of time raw fish candida and
mussels and oysters how to test just if
you take it and you feel a lot better
you're good go ahead and press your cap
and see if there's any tenderness go
ahead and press your cap and raise your
hand if you have any tenderness oh it
could be b1 deficient but you'd normally
will feel a sudden release of like
stress when you take b1 if you're
deficient so you're gonna feel a lot of
why I feel so much better
there's a test called Raglan so if you
get if you lay down take the blood
pressure and you stand up and the blood
pressure drops the systolic drops too
too far and you get dizzy you usually
are b1 deficiency you have b1 deficiency
vitamin D can really help insulin
resistance